alors j'ai 47 ans je suis juriste tu
mates et la nuit je viens de cinéma j'ai
18 ans je suis en terminale il a rien
d'autre à kiel 23 ans j'ai 20 ans j'ai
intégré les républicains il ya à peine
quelques mois très heureux d'être un
nouvel adhérent ci deviennent d'évidence
pour moi parce que je fais partie d'une
vague comme ça qu'ils aient envie de
donner son avis et que j'ai eu la
maturité nécessaire pour faire ce choix
je les fais sans hésiter et c'était bien
évidemment chez les républicains qu'il
allait que j'allais m'engager depuis les
attentats de janvier de novembre les
gens ont envie de s'engager que sedan
normes et dans la politique dans mon cas
c'était un petit peu une urgence il
fallait que j'intègre en parti politique
en vue d'apporter son énergie ses idées
il fonde nos convictions faudrait que je
les partage être les autres en fait j'ai
des choses cette idée optimistes comme
quand on peut toujours arriver à changer
des choses à faire des choses j'ai
jamais renoncer à quoi que ce soit mais
je pense que la politique c'est
tout faire pour que les gens vivent
mieux mais je pense que les citoyens ont
besoin de se réapproprier la politique
notamment aux adhérents d'un parti peut
être que je n'ai pas oublié le moment de
ma propre vie où j'ai pris ma carte à
l'époque de lui des airs pour la
première fois me souviens très bien je
suis rentré dans une permanence sur 1974
et j'avais la carte de monde
parti dans la poche je pensais que les
gens me regardaient différemment
ça choix qui engagent
toutes les consultations qu'on a
notamment sur direct citoyens ça nous
permet de prendre vraiment enfin d'avoir
notre place il met en avant le côté
démocratique d'un parti nous prend au
sérieux on peut donner notre avis on
sait écouter nous écoute beaucoup c'est
important parce que justement on prend
en compte notre point de vue on a le
droit à la parole
on nous dit vous avez le choix et donc
du coup bas allez-y dites nous